you know what does this movie represent
to you in your life at this current
moment the Fitz is really powerful for
me you know this is my directorial debut
in the narrative form and i co-wrote
this with two other women who are my
really close friends my editor cilia
Davis and my producer Lee secure Hoff
and we made this entirely with grant
support and it's just been a real labor
of love both from us and from our crew
and from the q-kidz are you know our
real collaborators on this process so
it's very special to kind of have it out
with audiences and to be landing and the
message is really about you know
community not conformity and the fact
that this was such a collaborative
process and that narratives about how it
was made but also I think it's the story
of the film so it's really special for
it to be connecting with audiences when
you think about the positives that doing
the Fitz has brought to your life can
you name one more than other that really
just stands out for you that you'll
never forget I think the connection with
the q-kidz you know we cast 45 real
teenage dancers in this film and they're
part of a dance team and Cincinnati
called the q-kidz and connecting with
them collaborating with them really
creating this film together hey I could
never forget it but also i feel like
we're entangled for the rest of our
lives and have a real family in
cincinnati and just excited about
watching all those girls grow and
explore new things and staying on the
sidelines as a cheerleader for them as I
kind of go forth it's really exciting
any recommendations to other producers
or directors on finding talent on
YouTube because I believe that's where
you initially discovered them yeah I
found them on on YouTube but it was
months of searching really and I also
was doing some in-person scouting as
well I think it's just about trusting
your gut and kind of allowing yourself
to be surprised really you know drill
wasn't something that we were actively
seeking it was just a recommendation
that came up through the YouTube you
know YouTube wreck
and recommends yeah and I think kind of
being open and instead of narrowing your
gaze open it up and be willing to be
surprised I think you mentioned that you
saw in the main actress which is a
royalty Hightower yeah please Tony when
you auditioned her you saw something in
her face that was the ability to listen
yeah I find that interesting why was
that important for her character royalty
is an amazing listener and it's she's
not just listening to me as a director
she's also listening to her fellow
performers and to herself she seems to
be always processing always very active
as a listener and tony is a really
challenging part in the script we
already knew she was going to be
carrying almost every single frame of
the film and as an actor I think we were
really looking for someone who was able
to reflect the world on her face and to
dance with her face in a way so the fact
that she's engaged naturally as a person
and really actively listening I think
was the first step to saying yeah I
think I think she can be Tony and she
exceeded all expectations she's just a
generous collaborator and performer what
were the conversations like on set with
royal with royalty yeah we talked about
a lot of things a lot of it was very
physical we would do I started wearing
basically gym clothes to set every day
because it was like we would joke
sometimes we were making a
feature-length workout video is just so
active and we would do sprints and we
would we would chat and we would do
dance exercises to kind of get into
character and start to embody these
movements but we were also talking about
really subtle things like being in a
daydream or being in a haze or kind of
what it was like to remember what she
was thinking about and playing around
with very you know lip placement I
placement because out of the time it's
just her face in the frame so it was all
kind of micro expression coaching and
was really fun
in terms of working with the camera what
what did you guide royalty on working
with the camera with the camera i think
it was always telling her that small
movements were okay i think as a dancer
often your audience is very far away so
the movements that you're doing as a
performer need to be bigger because
someone in the back of a auto torium or
the back of a gymnasium needs to be able
to see those expressions they're very
big and letting her know that the
audience is only a few inches away so
you can everything we could make smaller
and focused and more minut and I think
that that was something that we explored
kind of bringing down the performance
and breaking it down into smaller beats
I like how the undercurrent of the Fitz
is about how group's project identity is
someone and how Tony is able to kind of
flow between these two worlds maybe
easily maybe not so easily yeah can you
talk about that because any young woman
growing up in high school or man for
that matter yeah can relate to all that
well we made oh you know very kind of
exaggerated gender spaces there's like
the boys world and the girls world and
its really Tony's character who is able
to to permeate between those two spaces
and what we wanted to talk about
particularly in the beginning of film is
how the context is part of the identity
so nothing about her changes she just
walks from one room to another and she's
seen very differently because the
context of her body the context of her
identity shifts with what the group is
reflecting on her so we were playing
around with a lot of those things about
yeah how how identity is reflected
within the context of a group I like how
you created a lot of suspense and some
of these fearful moments because any
young woman going into like a locker
room yeah remember the you know I I felt
sick to my stomach points like oh my
gosh because it brought back memories
yeah going there and i co-wrote you know
with two women and we always were kind
of sharing those stories and making Venn
diagrams
saying what falls in the middle must be
these kind of universal beats and the
locker room is one of them you know just
really remember that feeling of being
like I need I'm gonna have to get
undressed in front of a group and and to
fear and unfamiliar and unfamiliarity of
those moments I think it's really about
fear of yourself and fear of being seen
and that yeah I think they're
particularly tied to fears of young
women but I I assume that crosses the
the gender line and yeah just kind of
really putting ourselves in the mind
space of what it means to be 11 in that
and 11 as a as a complex human being you
know right and she's a very mature 11
yeah even though she's feel small in
stature yeah I just see so much what's
going on yeah in her eyes how many pages
was the script our script is you know
pretty one to one in terms of screen
time two minutes oh is it was I think
between 68 75 pages which is our run
time of the film too and so I know was
co-written between the three of you yeah
did did you each approach it in a
different way where you took it the
ideas home on a weekend and brought
together in a we we did a lot of the
script work talking out loud in a room
and then I would return home and do the
page work to kind of keep the voice of
the page consistent and then we would
commonly tear it apart and break it
break it out and then I would return and
try to do that and then we also you know
in the writing process dialogue was
really placeholder because we wanted to
invite the actors to be authors
alongside us in the process so they were
able to rewrite all their own dialogue
and we spent I spent about six weeks on
location before I started shooting where
we were really workshopping the script
and and kind of getting to play and
explore and then putting that back on
the page so really continuing the
writing process right up through filming
so many filmmakers that we talked to see
things that the audience does not things
that they get critical about was there
anything that when you
the film even though the audience loves
it maybe you say ooh if I could change
this I think I would have been happier
or do you feel a sense of completion I
really do feel very at peace with the
film it still makes me cry so I think
that it's working it's still working on
me yeah the end sequence I get chills i
tear up pretty much every time i see it
so i feel like it's the film we set out
to make and it exceeds that in many ways
for me i think i'm still seeing things
that probably audiences for the first
time don't see but they're things i love
i think that there's so many details
that maybe take time to to see because
there's so much movement happening and
you know i think that there's many
layers there so yeah I feel good about
it's so hard to pull off a film that's
just in one location yeah you do
beautifully i know you move around the
pool but it's pretty much a central
location were there other films that you
watched that had one location and did
you know certain things that you wanted
to emulate yeah one of the big
references for us was Hunger Steve
McQueen's first narrative feature and
kind of using the tension of
claustrophobia and isolating the
audience in those spaces was something
that I think he did beautifully and
poetically in that film and then yeah
there was also you know in that choice
there was also kind of a practical
implication it ultimately allowed us
more hours of shooting because we
weren't doing company moves and and the
days were short already so we wanted to
just work with actors but the community
center where we filmed I feel like had a
very lived-in beautiful quality about it
and we you know my DP game on two weeks
before we did sun charts for every room
we really tried to emphasize what the
beautiful things that we were seeing
about that space in the film when you
consider whether a movie need
to be made what does filmmaking mean to
you what is that litmus test like for
you
because there's so many doesn't least
there could be made right now there's
but I think do they really need to be me
yeah i think when we were thinking about
the fits and whether it needed to be
made for us we think that films who I
don't know like personally has an artist
it's like you know is it I would wake up
in the middle of the night like thinking
about it you know and it's just like
something that wasn't going to go away
until it was made and so there's kind of
like a direct kind of obsession driving
factor that I think a lot of filmmakers
probably would understand but then in a
larger context yeah just you know
there's I think there's a pretty narrow
focus for for what does get made and
it's exciting I think to insert voices
outside of that narrow focus and if you
can do that and connect to it I think
that's really important but I think it's
much much harder task to set out to do
for me it was really just yeah I
couldn't I couldn't sleep if I didn't
make it so yeah